cuáles fueron las razones que los llevó
a tomar esta decisión
buenas noches y andrés de toda la
audiencia a la corte constitucional
consideró que el acto legislativo que
modificaba en nuestra construcción en
realidad correspondía a una sustitución
de un eje axial en la constitución de
colombia cuál es la dignidad humana
colombia es un estado social de derecho
fundado en el reconocimiento de la
dignidad humana y la corte estimó que la
cadena perpetua más en las condiciones
de nuestro sistema penitenciario y
carcelario que pues es no no es claro
que respete la dignidad equivalía a una
pena cruel e inhumana y degradante y que
por lo tanto afectaba gravemente el
orden constitucional además de eso
reconoció también que era un retroceso
en materia de humanización del sistema
penitenciario es decir era un retroceso
la diferencia de lo que pasó en otros
países donde la pena de muerte se
sustituyó por la cadena por la cadena
perpetua en colombia no fue así no
existía la pena de muerte sino esto es
un retroceso en la mano el derecho
magistrada que opina sobre las
declaraciones del presidente iván duque
al respecto y se lo voy a leer
textualmente dice una de las fallas de
nuestra sociedad es que pareciera que
hay más garantías para los victimarios
que para las víctimas
y yo pienso que el presidente se
equivoca no hay una
evidencia empírica que demuestre que la
cadena perpetua proteger a los niños
todo lo contrario los estudios que
duraban en el expediente mostraban que
este tipo de delitos contra la vida
integridad sexual de los menores se
cometen sobre todo en el ámbito familiar
en el ámbito doméstico y entre más grave
sea la pena es más difícil que los
familiares del delincuente lo denuncien
o testifican en su contra en un proceso
judicial entonces estas penas tan tan
severas como la cadena perpetua antes
que proteger a los niños pueden más bien
producir el efecto contrario es decir
desestimular la denuncia
y el proceso de testimonio y contra el
delito magistrada cara de usted que el
presidente probablemente tomó a este
tema con fines políticos sabiendo que
esta ley iba a caerse y así quizá
mejorar su afectada popularidad
pues no lo sé exactamente pero la corte
constitucional de colombia desde el año
1998 viene advirtiendo sobre el estado
de cosas inconstitucional en nuestro
sistema penitenciario y carcelario y
sobre la incoherencia de la política
criminal y sobre el populismo punitivo
que existe entre nosotros pues es una
tendencia digamos estructural de
nuestros políticos y el congreso de la
república querer ganar popularidad
mediante mediante la imposición de penas
muy graves para la función de los
delitos que al parecer es algo que le
produce tranquilidad a la sociedad pero
que no tiene necesariamente el efecto
que se busca poner magistrada y
rápidamente qué alternativas entonces
sugiera usted para poder acabar con esta
problemática
pues esta problemática yo creo que debe
atacarse de manteniendo pues también
penalizados estos benditos pero
acudiendo a otras estrategias como la
educación como el fortalecimiento de
nuestro sistema de protección familiar
nosotros tenemos una institucionalidad
vigorosa encabeza el instituto
colombiano de nuestra familiar de un
equipo muy grande de defensores de
familia con presencia en todo el
territorio nacional de una jurisdicción
de familia en donde también se pueden
adoptar otro tipo de medidas cuando los
niños están siendo abusados o
violentados en el seno de sus propias
familias
tenemos toda suerte de recursos para
para lograr su protección
y pues obviamente también la
penalización pero sin necesidad de penas
que aíslen a la persona para siempre la
sociedad le impiden volver a
socializarse y volver a formar parte del
grupo social volverá a vivir en
democracia y participar en la comunidad